but there's a balance here and i'm
curious how you align
with this idea it's called like the
dreamed symphony in the sense that
the infinite consciousness creates the
dreamed
reality that is that is this and then
there's the
multiverse which is all of the dreamed
realities this is just one
observers and there's many other
observers
happening an an infinite amount
of illusory finity in a sense
that is happening and so here you here
here we have this this um dimensionless
singularity that is indivisible
and it's indescribable the the
the dow that can be named is not the
eternal dao okay so we have that and
then now we
are the um this the dream symphony and
so here's the symphony that's happening
now in the symphony i'm playing the
violin
but you're playing the trombone and then
someone else is playing the clarinet and
someone else is playing the cello
and we're all playing different melodies
and different harmonies
and people that are playing out of tune
are people like you described that are
suffering they're still suffering
they're still
in the service to self mentality and
people that are playing
in tune are playing in the service to
other
mentality everything's in service
they're they've they've a clear
gnosis of the divine
that they are and what and what's going
on they're very
clear seer of truth consciousness
how do you resonate with that dreamed
symphony analogy
ben that's [ __ ] heavy
but i